hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we talked about line rendering
and rectangle rendering check out that
video if you haven't already it will be
linked there uh today we're going to
move on and we're going to kind of we've
been doing like rendering related
features and i mentioned that that is
mostly because of like the need to have
some kind of debug rendering graphics
inside our engine to validate like our
physics colliders now that we have most
of those things we can run in circles
looking at lines and rectangles
let's switch kind of gear back into the
physics system which is really what this
is all about and i want to specifically
integrate um circle colliders because we
don't actually support circle colliders
yet inside of the engine and that is
something that box 3d supports so let's
dive into it so at the moment if we take
a look at our scene and where we kind of
left off we have these well if i hit
play this is what the scene looks like
lovely we have these kind of um like
rectangles here in our scene these
sprites and then
uh we have a rigid body 2d and a box
collider 2d component both of those
components on these actual entities now
that results in this being able to
collide right and then this this square
over here actually has a dynamic rigid
body versus this which is a static rigid
body that's why these don't move and
that one does but the problem is we
obviously can't collide with this circle
at the moment i would like to be able to
collide with this circle so what we need
to do is set up a different type of
collider called a circle collider now i
did have some reference codes somewhere
because i did actually add this on a
live stream i think a week ago
but or maybe more than that maybe it was
like before optimization october not
sure but i don't know where it is so i'm
gonna have to implement this from
scratch off the top of my head so this
should be fun
um let's go into uh
the way that i like to like make
components because like our first step
is gonna be to introduce this new
component right we need a new component
type we have a box glider 2d component
but we also need a circle collider
component
now the thing is i am not 100 sure what
we should put in here like things like
maybe radius and whatever makes sense um
i mean we will still take like the
transform component of the entity into
consideration so we'll probably multiply
the scale with that or whatever or the
radius with that scale
but um aside from that like i don't know
what else potentially should be here
it's pretty uh it's pretty like likely
that obviously density friction
restitution stuff like that will still
remain for circle colliders but instead
of us kind of guessing all of this and
trying to figure out what should be here
the way that i in general like to like
write like to write code
is by kind of working backwards so if we
go to scene instead
of trying to like guess all this stuff
if we go to scene and we see where we
add a box collated component let's take
a look at how we would add a circle
collider component well again if it has
a circle collider component what exactly
am i going to do well i need to
basically so we'll get that circle
collider 2d component instead of setting
a polygon shape let's go to that
actually i'm just going to go into box
2d which we have over here source
i don't know man like collision maybe so
we have a circle shape this is kind of
what i'm looking for and circle shape
is in the box to the api section here
circle shape so this is a shape
and this shape i think has a radius so
actually every shape has a radius here
in the bass class so we can obviously
we'll obviously use that but then the
circle itself you can see it doesn't
have a radius it just has a position so
we have a position for it which can kind
of act as the offset i guess maybe we'll
see how this works and then we have a
radius and then we have a lovely api we
can use like raycast test point compute
abb compute mass all of that kind of
stuff which is nice as well
so we know that these are kind of the
parameters that we already expect to
have inside our circle collider now it's
totally okay for you to just be like you
know what doesn't matter i don't want to
have a radius parameter i'm just going
to use the transform that's totally fine
why might you not want that
well
you might not want you might want to
have a separate radius that you can use
to control the radius so that it's
different from the transform radius or
not different but used in conjunction
with that as like almost like a modifier
or a multiplier to that transform scale
the reason why you might want that
radius is just in case
uh you know because the transform
component itself and the scale there
obviously affects more than just
the circle collider component like if
i'm actually rendering a circle or a
sprite it's going to affect like the
rendering behavior of that
by having a radius as a separate
parameter a separate kind of
like value that we can change inside the
actual circle collider component i'm
able to set it to a different value than
what the transform component scale is
does that make sense hopefully that
makes sense but there are still ways
around that so even if we didn't have
the radius value we could still for
example have the actual renderable
entity as a child entity of the parent
and the parent is the thing that has the
circle collider that way we could set
the parent scale to whatever we want it
to be so that the circle collider is the
right size and then obviously since the
child is a child of that it will go
wherever the parent is so the physics
system will kind of simulate that parent
and that all of the child entities maybe
there's just one which is that sprite
that we're rendering that would
obviously
you know be affected by physics and all
of that stuff so you can also do it that
way that complicates the hierarchy a
little bit and i'm all about giving
people options so that's why i'm going
to set it up here but just a little bit
of discussion
around that issue just so that you guys
can kind of see just what i'm thinking
about and what i'm taking into
consideration when i write this code
so circle shape
uh and then i don't think we have to do
set as box i actually don't really know
how to do this as i mentioned i
uh i don't have any reference code but
it looks like we can just make it and
then set the position and the radius
which is on the base class so let's just
set
let's just make a circle shape which i
think we have to it's an incomplete type
so let's go up here and just include
circle shape
and then so we'll get that circle shape
i won't worry about setting it as a box
or anything we'll just do circle shape
dot now the
position
which is mp right does that matter so
that's just a stack allocated object
which by default does nothing which is
probably bad because it won't actually
set it to zero
so there is a set zero we should
probably do that because i'm assuming
that position
how do we actually set the position of
even this though so we've got size and
scale create fixture so this doesn't
actually
care about the position i think the
the body we do body def position set
so i don't think we need to worry about
this what i think this is is probably an
offset parameter so we'll just do set 0
just to make sure that's zeroed out
and then let's do radius
because otherwise it'll be just
uninitialized memory which is not good
as far as i understand
and then radius we will set to whatever
that radius parameter is going to be so
we don't have that yet but you can see
kind of how i'm working backwards
because i'm going to create that and
then we'll take in the circle shape the
density and all of this stuff this is
more or less physics material territory
in my opinion but we don't have a
physics material yet so we'll kind of
make it like so and i think that's
probably it so you can see that
basically the only thing we really need
is the radius otherwise everything else
stays the same as it would be
for
the uh box collider 2d so let's get rid
of this again i don't know having an
offset
let's you know what let's play with that
because i definitely didn't do that
during the live streams let's have some
fun let's also have an offset so we'll
what we'll do is the offset by default
is in fact zero and then this is what
i'm actually going to do i'm actually
going to set this
we can just use set to be that dot
offset dot x and that dot offset dot y
and then the radius
which
why is that so upset because that's a
vector for some reason
good work churno
so point five is the radius because one
meter is the diameter
and yeah that should be okay so now if
we have a circle collider component then
we are good to go now let's go into the
scene hierarchy panel quickly add all of
the ui this should be very easy because
a lot of it is actually the same so if
we go to box collider component we'll
just make sure that we add this
circle clutter component i'm probably
gonna somewhat automate the way the
components are made and all of this
stuff because this is all the same it's
once we have that list of components
it's really easy to generate this stuff
from it we can also have a names or some
kind of metadata attached to component
which are components which i think will
be good as well um
like we've got a few things well i mean
we could have a registry of component
type to name and all of that stuff so
that we don't store the name in the
actual kind of component i've got some
ideas that i want to do because in big
hazel
it's all manual as well at the moment
which is not scaling well because we
have like 20 components i think and it's
just getting a bit annoying
uh we'll add the drop the draw component
as well
so we've got draw component
this is a circle collider obviously
and offset
radius
this is just a normal
radius
everything else literally stays the same
so you can see it's like super simple to
do this now for the for for it to
actually be played and everything we
need to make sure that when we copy this
scene
we copy the circle collider component
and also i think we also copy component
stuff over here
so this is the duplicate entity function
so we'll make sure that we do that i
like to just go through one of the
components yeah we need to do this thing
haha i was about to get a linking error
like literally every episode when i add
a new component but not today
because i've outsmarted the system
okay that looks good to me so i think
apart from serialization which we'll
just check in now
um
we're pretty much done so this is the
serialization
replace box with circle probably a bit
faster to do a find replace
but it's okay
circle collided 2d component
and then obviously we do radius instead
of size otherwise everything else stays
the same i'm really interested in
checking out that offset thing we'll do
that we'll do that in a minute
and
the deserialization obviously is also
important
so circle collider
2d
circle collided 2d component
pop all that stuff in
trying to speed run this
radius radius
and
all that okay
um yes and this is a float
i think that's good uh yeah i think we
just pretty much fully added circles and
it's been like 12 minutes is that real
is this real life i don't know
let's not
talk too soon shall we
um okay
so
we have this circle let's try and make
this collide with it right so we'll go
to add component circle collider 2d i'll
leave it everything as is okay that's
already wrong because this is actually
showing density
um but if we hit play
it doesn't work
it was i was so close no it's okay
actually i think i know why it's because
it doesn't have a rigid body
yep
it works
and then for fun we'll make it dynamic
and we should see it roll down
beautiful okay easy easy
now uh let's check out that offset
parameter we'll fix the ui in a minute
but yeah so what's happening here is
this is a float in memory but we're
actually sending it into an i'm going
drag float to
so it's obviously going past the memory
address it's going to the next memory
and it's just the next thing in the
struct is the density so if i drag this
you can see it's actually dragging both
of these
all right
um because what i'm doing is controlling
the density
or controlling the the memory
manipulating the data at the memory
address that is for density
um now the offset so if i offset this by
like 0.5 what's what's gonna happen
let's put this back to static
yeah so it looks like yeah it looks like
what it's done is it's just shifted it
so it's actually like over here now
and if i hit play
um we should see the y be correct but
the x maybe not let me just back this
camera up a bit like to 7 or something
because it's a little bit too close
and then we'll go back here and we'll
make it dynamic
yeah okay wow that actually looks quite
interesting so it looks like
so what have we really done we've just
shifted it by
it's hard to tell isn't it but it looks
like it's over here well yeah we know
that it's over here
but i'm just surprised that it fell on
the y-axis as well
oh maybe it rotated let's let's fix the
rotation
yeah that looks a bit
better maybe
but now it looks like it's
like here that's weird as well
sometimes it's hard to see what's going
on if you don't have um
the visual the physics visualization
this is exactly why we're building all
this physics visualization stuff by the
way because otherwise it literally does
not make any sense
um so let's maybe try this let's let's
put this um
here
so what's going on with this camera it's
still the camera is still in a rubbish
location
i want to kind of what's the zero zero
let's just move the camera like here
yeah that's better so um
let's try and what am i trying to do
let's make the offset
we'll put it like 0.5 on y which will
push it up it should push it up
and then what i'll do as a test is so
0.5y will offset it to be here
so if i put this to
so what's that roughly
one point so i would like to have it at
1.74
but if i
subtract
sorry if i add let's just do 2.24
that's 0.5 right so this should be
it should still be where it was before
and just for fun i'm going to duplicate
this circle we're going to use this as a
visualizer i'll make this like this
color and i'll actually pull it up to
what it was which was 1.74 so basically
oh and it will obviously get rid of like
the
the
physics components from it so this does
not have any physics components anymore
this is just purely for rendering
and then
what it should be though is the location
of the collider of this entity so
the cube should collide with this kind
of teal circle if that makes sense
and it as you can see it looks like it
works
okay so that's probably good enough for
me um
if we wanted to try and offset it again
let's let's do the same for the x-axis
so i'll put this to like 1.72
so it's 0.5 that way and then i will
simply
make the uh
offset minus 0.5
and i should still collide with the teal
thing yeah there we go okay so it looks
like the teal thing has a collider but
it doesn't because obviously if i reset
this back to zero zero for the offset on
the orange circle then well there you go
right
oh and it's actually dynamic still yeah
it is interesting
cool anyway so that is now the offset
working let's just quickly fix i'll i
won't save that scene i'll quickly fix
the
bug here with uh
drag float two so it's just a drag float
little typo and this looks like in just
about the shortest episode
the shortest and sweetest episode
of the game engine series yet and then
we'll just um
i guess i'll update this to be cool so
i'll i'll put this here
well you know what let's just roll it
down
we'll we'll make it dynamic so we'll add
a circle collider and a rigid body 2d
dynamic
and there you go fun times i will
definitely end up moving that camera
though because it looks terrible
where it is that looks much better cool
beautiful there's our scene so thank you
guys for watching hope you enjoyed the
video if you did please don't forget to
hit that like button i hear youtube is
doing away with dislikes now so only i
can see them so make sure you slap that
like button if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to help support the series
on patreon.com the churno uh you'll get
access to bighazel where you'll be able
to keep up with like all of the cool 3d
stuff that we're doing if that interests
you more and obviously the funds kind of
from that go towards basically producing
this series towards producing
like to actually getting people to work
on hazel and all that stuff so it's a
great community and obviously it's
something that we we're kind of building
over time and it's very exciting so
thank you all for your wonderful support
next time what are we going to do next
time um
i think we are probably going to i think
we're ready to actually finally start
actually adding in those visualizers
that we talked about because we've got
circle colliders we've got
uh rectangle or box colliders so there
are still a lot of physics things that i
want to do but i feel like we're almost
like at that first kind of vertical
slice where we've got like
enough things to be able to people start
making games but i still want to like
explore you know various like joints and
uh some other kind of things as well but
maybe they'll be a little bit better to
do when we actually have interaction via
c sharp so we'll see what order we do
that in but that is probably what will
happen thank you guys for watching i
will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you